I'm very excited to be here thank you
everyone for being here I'm going to
talk about a recent result on sighs free
generalization bounds for consonants and
this is joint work with Filan recently
we've had substantial progress in
theoretical analysis of generalization
in deep learning and I'm very excited
that many of the authors that I've cited
are actually here in this room and the
detailed of the details of citations are
all in the appendix of disguise I
couldn't write all the details so we've
had a lot of progress and something
interesting that has been noted with
roots in Peters earlier results is that
even if there are many parameters the
set of models computable by using the
base with the small magnitude is limited
enough such that we can actually use
induction and that's has been used in
Vorta to tell 2017 and they shall be at
all 2018 intuitively when we start with
the small weights and the algorithms
that be usually used make small progress
through our training and as we get
closer to the optimal point their steps
become smaller and smaller so we are
essentially getting into small weights
and so there is tendency for the
algorithms that be used to produce the
small weights which is analyzed in
detail as implicit bias of learning by
Surya at all and tangu also has worked
out what we're interested in is distance
to initialization there's been even more
recent recent results and generalization
bounds in terms of distance from initial
setting of the weights instead of the
size of debates and again this has been
used imported at O and 2017 and they
shall be at all 2019 one thing that is
important to note is that the small
initial weights may promote vanish
ingredients so instead it's advisable
that we choose initial weights that
maintain a strong but non exploding
signal as computation flows through the
network and this has been advised by
many works so what we do what we know
recently is that for a large
twork initialize display a variety of
though behave functions can be found
through training where there has been
actually it's the trial there has been
actually a short distance traveling
parameter space so what the point I want
to make is that the distance from
initialization may be it may be expected
to be significantly smaller that the
weight magnitude furthermore there is
theoretical reason to expect that as we
get more and more over Proma and
parameters as the number of parameters
increases the distance from
initialization decreases but we are
focusing on here is generalization band
four countenance as we all know
convolutional layers are used in all
competitive deep neural network
architectures that are applied to vision
and image processing tasks and the most
influential generalization analysis in
terms of distance initialization so far
have only focused on fully connected
layers of course we can think of
convolution as a Reaper in a Reaper
amortization and think of it as a fully
connected and then use all the earlier
results however if we do that we are
missing an important property of
convolution which is very time and
intuitive leave a tying importing the
convolutional layer is constraining the
set of possible functions computed by
each layer and this additional
restriction is expected to a
generalization so I hope so for now as
so far I've convinced you that it's
important to look into this thing and in
summary this is the result we get our
bounds are in terms of the training loss
the number of parameters the Lipchitz
constant of the loss and the distance of
the weights to initialization and they
are independent of the number of pixels
in the input and the height and width of
the hidden feature maps and I want to
emphasize that this is the first
supervised learning bounds for deep
convolutional networks that have this
property so let's recap what we mean by
convolution of course I know that this
audience doesn't need this recap but
just to make sure we are all on the same
page
so when we talk about convolution we are
talking about a discrete convolution and
this is linear combination of pixels
applied locally so this is your input
you have a kernel that moves around the
input and generates the output at
different locations so of course like
any other linear operator we can write
convolution in terms of a matrix vector
product so here is an example I have a
1d convolution the upper part is the
input then the small vector is the
kernel and if you think of this
convolution in terms of a matrix matrix
vector product this is the form of the
matrix here I'm ignoring the edge
effects and the matrix and this matrix
corresponding to convolution is what
what is what we refer to as operator
matrix and the notation we use is up of
K where K is your cap of course we have
more complicated settings you can have a
two-dimensional single channel
convolution and if K is your kernel then
the operator matrix corresponding to it
can be the can be calculated directly by
some form of sequence analysis and again
we refer to that up of cake
we have extensively analyzed convolution
for 2d case and multi-channel
convolution in our earlier results this
is the paper we just had at eichler so
what we did was that the analyze this
mathematically and we proposed an a
simple and efficient algorithm to find
the full spectrum of the convolution and
we proposed upper bounds for the
spectral norm of these convolutions and
also we proposed an algorithm to project
the convolutional layer into a set of
bounded operator number which can be
extended into 3d multi-channel
convolution and so on so the reason for
this for mentioning is this that in the
rest of the top album and are we talking
a lot about the spectral number of the
operator matrix corresponding to
convolution and I want to mention that
whenever I say that please note that we
already have a good algorithm is simple
and efficient to find that so let's get
it started
I will start with a basic setting let's
say I have an L layer convolutional net
you have the usual zero padding and
pulling and the activation functions
that we all have in the network or one
Lipschitz and non-expensive
for example we have we can have regular
tannic you have a tensor input which has
C channels and if you Victor as your
input and you can look at the l2 norm of
that is bounded by one the number of
channels throughout the network is C and
you have L kernels and the dimension of
your kernels are K by K times C by C so
if you think of total number of
parameters essentially we have lk
squared C squared total number of
parameters the loss function be half we
assume it's lambda Lipchitz for all the
value of labels a famous example of this
is margin loss where if you have a
margin loss with margin of land oh it's
gone over lambda Lipschitz another
assumption we make is that the maitre d
operator matrix related to kernels at
initialization it's a spectral norm is 1
please take a look at this value that
I've mentioned here so we define the
distance to initialization here as sum
over all the layers of the difference of
operator matrix to its initialization
and the spectral norm of that note that
they did not the difference between this
this value and the earlier results where
the where the distance earlier works
looked at was product over all the
layers here we are looking at distance
initialization and sum over all the
layers and the set of functions we are
interested in is that the set of
function where this distance to the
initialization define this way is
bounded by some value beta so what we
prove is that in this setting with high
probability the difference between
expected error and empirical error is
bounded by this value which is linear in
terms of number of parameters linear in
terms of the upper bound on the distance
initialization and has logarithmic
dependence towanda which is the
Lipschitz constant corresponding to the
loss function that you have
also as there has been discussions about
interpolations as much as the
interpolation is interesting but we seen
practice is that when we are optimizing
for a good test error the value of the
empirical loss is not zero so this case
is still interesting for us to
understand further now let me get a
little bit into the whole level I the
high level idea behind how we prove this
in order to say that let's recap on two
definitions one is the definition of
full norm we are saying is a norm over R
to the D is feu if it's unit ball has
positive volume another definition we
need is an is the definition of
Lipschitz parameterize models so let me
G be a set of functions with a common
domain Z we say that G is B and D
Lipschitz parameterize where D is the
dimension and V is the Lipschitz
constant if there is a full norm on all
over D where any mapping from the unit
bulb with respect to this Norman Rd to G
is such that for all theta and theta
prime where there you know over there l2
norm is bounded by 1 if you look at the
difference between this mapping of fee
over tto vs. mapping of e over t2 prime
this is bounded by some value B
difference between theta and here prime
and this definition is the core idea
behind what I'm going to talk about so
the most important lemma that we use for
proving our results is this lemma where
talks about this that if you have a
strategy of functions from Z to some
bounded interval 0 and M and this set of
functions is B and D Lipschitz
parameterize then for any ADA there
exist some C such that if you have large
enough number of samples with high
probability you have this difference
have this found on difference between
expected an empirical risk which is
linear in terms of upper bound and loss
and linear in terms of dimension and has
blueberry tweak dependence to B which is
your Lipschitz constant and what we do
is that given that we have this lemma
what we do is that we show that the set
of loss fun the set of loss functions
already said that we talked about is
beta lambda e to the beta and W Lipsius
parameterize just as a reminder beta is
the upper bound on the distance to
initialization lambda is your Lipschitz
constant corresponding to loss and W is
the number of parameters you have so if
you put this together essentially we are
done and we have where we are able to
prove our results if you're eager to
know more a little bit more we can dig
further so where does that lemma come
from the first part is actually old news
it's all the way back from vapnik and
chairborne and case from 1971 and vapnik
and polar what is new relatively new not
independent era new is this result from
Gina and Gullo from 2001 and this is
interesting and this is something that
like we hadn't been using earlier
results and the secret behind this
really nice man which has blueberries
weak dependence on Lipschitz constant
and linear dependence to dimension is
that of course like we all use covering
bounds but when they when they use
covering bounds of the form P over bit
epsilon to the D they pay particular
attention to the dependence of resulting
generalization bound over B to B whereas
area results they were only thinking of
B as a constant and then they ignore
this relationship so what is left for me
to show you is that how do we find these
Lipschitz constant corresponding to the
set of functions that I define so but
usually as usual what we do is that we
want to see if the parameter changes
what happens in the loss in terms of
parameters
let's start with a simple case where
only now even you have two networks and
only the parameters in one layer changes
so as we as I mentioned we assume that
our loss is landed Lipschitz with
respect to his first argument so if you
want to bound the difference in loss
it's enough for us to bound the
differences for in function and then
multiply it by lambda how do we how do
we bound the difference in the function
what we think of is that I'm saying only
one linear parameter has changed let's
let me call that layer J and let me
explain the function of the neural
network in three steps so G AB is from
the input to the network all the way to
before level before the layer that have
changed and then I have the function and
the layer that is changed and then I
have the rest of the function that I
call eg of them so let me call you to be
G up of X by the assumption we had that
the l2 norm of input is bounded by one
and also our nonlinearities have
Lipschitz constant of one it's easy to
show that U is upper bounded by product
of the operator norm of operator matrix
of different kernels all the way up to
reality now if I want to look at it as a
whole essentially what we have is this
difference if you use the usual norm
under analysis you comes out and for the
rest of the layers after J you have
similar products so it becomes product
over all the other layers and then for
the layers that is changed we have a
spectral norm of difference between
operator matrix corresponding to this
kernel that is changed so the other
assumption we had was that that
initialization the spectral norm of
operator matrix of all of these is
bounded by one so we can write this in
terms of K - its initialization plus
initialization and we know the English
this branch initialization is bounded
for each layer by B I so this is what we
can now what we know so this is what we
had from last page I every I put
everything about in terms of loss and
broaden lambda so what we know is that
the sum of the distance to
initialization for all these layer is
beta so if I want to maximize product of
1 plus beta I what I do is that I said
all the beta is equal to beta over L so
this is what I get in the second line
and then we know that 1 plus beta over L
to the L is upper bounded by e to the
beta so we are done essentially now this
was the case where I only change the
parameters in one layers if we want to
look at difference between theta and all
the parameter is being changed we want
to look at all the layers and in order
to analyze that we look at the case
where we changed one layer at a time and
we used triangle inequality and this is
it we're done we proved
what is our lives constant corresponding
to our set of functions so we prove that
the loss functions corresponding to the
set of function is beta lambda e to the
beta and W Lipschitz parametrize now if
you put it back into the lemma that I
showed from vapnik
and Guinean goooooo essentially you get
the results so one thing that might be
one question that might arise is that we
are analyzing the same similar things to
part of the cell 2017 and so the
question is that how do they compare so
in order to be able to do this
comparison we consider convolution as a
fully connected Network and we look at
high probability bounds in terms of the
different generation gap or difference
between expected and empirical risk all
the details are in the paper here I'm
going to talk about a specific case
where you look at the case where
initialization computes identity and for
all the layers the value of your kernel
is the initial value plus epsilon added
to all the entries then this would this
is what happens our bounds simplifies to
the line above and Barta that holds 2017
bounds is the lower line and you can see
that in this scenario the new bound is
independent of D which is what we
promised initially and also it grows
more slowly with blonder number of
channels and depth
so let's talk about a more general
setting let's remove some of these
assumptions and make it closer to what
we have in practice again you have zero
padding you have pooling your
activations are non expansive you can
have else L sub C convolutional layers
and you can have L sub F fully connected
layer so your network has both fully
connected and convolutional layers your
input is tensor and we're assuming that
the Victory's version of the input has
some upper bound Kai and your output is
a tensor itself and of course we're not
making any assumptions on the number of
channels in different convolutional
layers it can be anything and but simply
make this assumption which holds in
practice that your loss is Landa
Lipchitz and also the loss at all these
values that you are estimating for your
network is has some it's between zero
and some value n here we loosen up the
assumption we had on the initialization
so essentially a spectral norm of the
operator matrix corresponding to your
initial kernel can be some upper bounded
by some value 1 plus mu so it's it's a
looser assumption compared to the
initial one we had and also for all the
fully connected layers respect their
initial spectral norm is bounded again
by some value 1 plus nu the notation we
use here so we use a VI to refer to
weights for the fully connected layers
and tidak is all our set of parameters
which means the kernels corresponding to
convolutions and the V is corresponding
to fully connected layers so your depth
is essentially L sub C plus L sub F the
distance to initialization that we look
at in this case is that for the all the
convolution of the year we take sum over
all of them the distance to
initialization of operator matrix the
spectral norm meaning and sum over all
the fully connected layers difference of
weights a fully connected base to their
initialization and the spectral norm of
that and we are interested instead of
functions where than this
- initialization defined this way is
bounded by some value beta and we are
able to prove this results so the this
result holds with high probability and
the difference between and expected an
empirical risk is bounded by this value
which is linear in terms of a upper
bound on the last function linear in
terms of number of parameters a linear
in terms of beta which is something
really interesting linear in terms of
depth of the network and also has
logarithmic dependency between lambda
and upper bound on size and size of your
input so one thing I want to mention is
that in our earlier paper in our clear
paper we showed that the spectrum norm
of the distance between any two kernels
can be essentially operator matrix
corresponding to kernels so the spectral
norm of operator matrix corresponding to
do different kernels can be upper
bounded if we vectorize those kernels
and look at the l1 value of this
difference so the same bounds can be
reached even if we replace our
definition of set of functions and
instead of using a spectral norm we use
l1 norm so if you like to use l1 norms
this you can get exact same results
another thing that I want to mention is
that the bounds that we proposed holds
uniformly for models that are all at a
distance beta from initialization but
this can be modified using standard
techniques to get non-uniform bound as a
function of distance itself
so let's do another comparison now that
we have results that directly hold for
fully connected networks
let's compare again with bounds of birth
date at all 2017 here we are taking away
the convolution we are comparing two
networks that have all three connected
layers and they're deep so we are saying
that each hidden layer has Big D
components and D classes where D is C D
squared C is number of channels and D is
the dimension of the input and for all
of them
we initialize them at identity and the
value of each layer is i plus h over
root t but these are Hadamard matrix now
it's easy given these values to compute
the spectral norms so spectral norm of
each V is equal to 2 and the distance
initialization spectral norm is 1 and
the 2 one norm used in Bartlett at all
distance initialization is because now
if we rewrite all those sounds the top
the top one is the bound that we get and
the lower part is the bound from
Bartlett at all and we can see we have
linear dependency with depth whereas
earlier result has exponential
dependency with
so let's switch gears and talk about
experiments if there is any questions
about to your subject yes generalization
this parameters yes so how does it
compare to and straightforward 50 pounds
yeah this is dimension selenium yeah
what's the difference so what what we
are what 1 1 and 1 thing that is new
that we are saying is that what are the
terms that we have in terms of distance
initialization and as I show in the
experiments and as it has been something
that more recently people have been
looking at is that how distance the
initialization changes and how it can be
produced to predict generalization so if
you make larger I assume you compute the
pounds you can see how it behaves when
the network dr. so things like the
distance even though the number of
parameters is going up because the
business is going down but overall
to go down so yes so that's something
that we've seen the experiments let's go
over the experiments and if there is any
experiments that you were asking for it
and we haven't done it then we can't
talk about it
okay so here's the setting we have a vga
style 10 layer called convolutional
model we have a c4 ten dataset we are
using dropout and the usual exponential
learning rate schedule what we do is
that we repeatedly trained different
trained the same network for different
values of batch size and initial
learning so we have a bunch of trained
networks and I'm going to refer to
generation gap many times for the slides
for the rest of the slides so just a
reminder generalization gap is what we
mean by difference between train and
test error so let's take a look so here
is generalization gap as a function of
total number of parameters time distance
initialization and each of these dots is
a generalization gap for one of the
networks that we train and we can see
there's there is we can see the
correlation between this value that we
are proposing and the generalization gap
itself so we did further analysis let's
look at generalization gap as a function
of W which is total number of parameters
so what I did here is that I increase
the total number of parameters by
keeping the depth fixed but increasing
the width of the network and as we can
see as the network becomes more and more
over Pam tries the generalization gap
remains almost flat another thing that
we worked at is that so what is
predicted by our ethical bounds is the
first plot but then we dig further to
look into what's gonna happen yes
so the other thing that we look at is to
distance is to look at distance to
initialization as a function of total
number of parameters the plot on the
right is looking at mean and error bar
for this distance initialization and the
other one is showing the median and as
we can see as we increase the number of
parameters what happens is that the
value of distance to initialization is
dropping another thing that we
experimented with we relates to role of
input size so earlier results they had
the generalization bound dependent on
the input size but we came up with an
avid analysis that is independent of the
role of input size because it we thought
intuitively that should be the case so
but we wanted to also check our
intuition with experiment so what we did
was that so see for 10 as we all know is
32 by 32 images we down sampled see for
10 images from 32 to 32 to 16 to 16 and
then we did everything all over again so
we trained all our networks and we
looked at the value of generalization
gap so this graph is the histogram of
generalization gap of this 10 layer
called count model that we had the green
shows the values for 32 by 32 images and
the red shows the values for 16 by 16
images and as we can see this support is
the same so this graph shows us that the
get generalization gap does not really
depend on input size and this is
something that our bounds had captured
so divide it so this is just a histogram
so the Vioxx is is that the number of
times that value happened in the number
of networks that we train and the x-axis
is the values of the generalization gap
that we observe yeah so this is
something that our bounds captured so we
did not use beta K here we only use drop
um I haven't tried that but we'll try we
can try it and I want to emphasize that
there was no bad so these are the
squeeze departments of historical
traditional dependency across different
random States so so what is the same is
the network architecture is the same and
the hyper parameters are tried over a
set of number of hybrid parameters for
example what we played with was batch
size 32 64 and 128 and the other thing
was the learning rate the schedule is
the same but the initial learning rate
the sweep sweep over a different number
of values so the network is the same the
hyper parameters initialization so
essentially what happens is that when
you make the input smaller your train
and test error both become a train and
test accuracy both becomes low and maybe
that's why it's more constant so when
you're reporting the x-axis they're not
to distinguish
the time so basically it's the
difference between train and test error
so what happens is that so that's what
they mean by generalization gap so what
happens is that when you make the size
is smaller the accuracy for both train
and test drops
what's the same conveyances yes I guess
there are some shows that you scale up
the resolution the transition becomes
better absolutely you need to give up
everything right right so yeah so
basically here we did not a scale up
everything we were mostly interested in
saying okay let's let me fix the network
architecture and look at what what
things changes if we make if we really
zoom in and like make this dimension of
the input way bigger than that I think
that's the regime that we haven't looked
through we haven't really run
experiments on that we haven't really
because if you make it really really
zoom in then architecture also an
incision
so in conclusion we provided the first
size free generalization pounds for deep
CN n models I want to emphasize that our
analysis applies to practical
architectures you can change your
activation functions and pooling
operators to have larger victories
constant that can be directly plugged in
into our analysis and also many variants
of our bounds are possible so what we
chose in the different variants that we
could show is that the ones that be
relatively simple and interpretable but
if like if you want to really dig into
the details and come up with more more
detailed analysis they're they're
actually possible and they're completely
doable given their analysis you can even
look at bounds in terms of Lipschitz
constant of sub networks that are
bounded above by a pitch of the beta or
you can so when I showed the Lipschitz
constant I showed all these loosening up
of the bounds that we did but you can
essentially not loosening up and it's
get additional results again the one we
were aiming for simple city and
interpretability and for future works
one thing we want to do is that we want
to use the insights that we learned to
use design regularizer x' for improving
training and generalization in practical
models the paper is available on archive
thank you all for listening
[Applause]
the first part yes so essentially the
loss function the most important thing
we need and the assumption on the loss
function that is has but is bounded in
some domain and also it's Lander
Lipschitz enter in as a function of the
boy which is the output this is yeah
these words were bounded was
and other questions okay so now it's
time to party
and so it's hopefully there is reception
either like outside here where we can
Ingle a bit talk about all the cool
result of be seen and even better watch
it see you tomorrow
[Applause]